what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation it is time to watch
Monarch episode dose today if you did
not catch our reaction to episode one
that is of course up here on this
channel hey John how you doing I am
delightful Greg how are you I'm doing
well doing well didn't realiz two
episodes came out so we're running late
to this my God ladies and Gentlemen
please go ahead Roar at that like button
or breathe fight whatever something
that's clever thank you to prep for
helping us Ed down these highlights also
subscribe click that notification Bell
cuz you know we going to be covering the
rest of Monarch thank you to everyone
who has joined our patreon full length
Reaction watch along that's where you
sync up with your own copy that is
available for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page we also cover
several things exclusiv over there with
highlights and watch alongs included all
right John you ready I am
[Music]
ready enter green onions just like
Godzilla's breath
oh I guess so it's an Easter egg
confirmed Lieutenant Shaw reporting is
ordered green onions is the name of the
song it's not green onions is it green
onions it's not green onions this is
this is uh what I say by Ray Charles
okay to got the song wrong think green
onions has a different vibe put it in
the
reaction you couldn't pick a fight with
one of them instead of two of our
own love character actor chrisop allll
what's a fight even
about I guess I just can't abide bullies
sir you're a good man some of them are
me oh what do you think he'd make of you
now he's back in the overlord movie some
orders have come through security escort
for a Japanese scientist oh this is when
he falls in love with her I already lost
a man on one of these escort missions a
couple of months back an escort Mission
Observe and Report when and if able
understood and that is all
Lieutenant dismissed
no my mom is from Manila guys oh damn
look out fun fact for yall sir uh you
don't happen to be Dr Mira sexist
Mira sorry you're not
[Laughter]
Ken they told me they were sending a
military escort and and you're the only
one here in uniform but you got lady
part you don't know
science mute
up Ko nice to meet you nice to meet you
so you must be his daughter ah I'm sorry
I think there's a little
miscommunication happening here um let's
start over yeah I think my my penis is
confusing me with what you are the
patriarchy and you may call me Dr yeah
[__] oh Green Onions by elv yes love
it they're going to oh this is the
original hound dog yeah oh my God what's
her name is it uh sister Rosetta Tharp
am I making you
nervous no this is an Army jeep and I'm
you know the Army I've been driving up
and down these roads for weeks I know
the way this is the way this is the way
this is the way okay then starting to
get the feeling you don't really want me
around here maybe your sexism got in the
way pretty far south for a Russian bomb
test I because it's not a Russian it's a
Titan well they were the wrong Isotopes
for bomb fall out and meteorological
data shows they likely originated here
the Philippines oh my God Godzilla's
Filipino that's
right put you guys on the map should get
to work hit the gas
doc
yeah she's also a race car dri driver
damn this is beautifully shot
yeah catching the disorienting ways of
the windy road wild looking beautiful
wonder if they actually shot in Manila
or if they just went to New Zealand
probably New Zealand's cheaper New
Zealand or Canada
baby oh now we get the opening credits
even more because of the dueling
identities see that with their names
shifting they're both Lee Shaw shame
Ko's not here there's so much duality in
these credits I know right and
duplicitousness what do I do about my
dad and my hot
sister and what if my other mom's
hot my man's plays guitar he's got mut
toy hey whose side are you on is that M
to mistake that look like some type of
Kaiju look like some kind of creature
yeah maybe it was just like a regular
dinosaur or have they merchandised the
MOs
[Music]
yet so many memories of the safe from
yesterday could have at least closed it
up to make it look like they didn't take
like the secret it come raid the safe
[Music]
yeah e the dad has the same exact photos
in America just he's on the opposite
side yeah
it's just a mirror of this
room is this destruction going to lead
to finding some type of document that's
like oh wait a minute it has to or an
artifact or a
[Music]
McGuffin always want to shoot one of
these kinds of distraught wreck the room
scenes there has been a lot of emphasis
on the keys on walking unlocking Secrets
yes the key to our
[Laughter]
Salvation
uhoh Leland Lafayette
III he's going to find daddy Russell
yeah
buddy oh yeah let's watch that old film
there's nothing but jolly commercials on
it why am I so emotional and craving
chicken un will be entirely gone and the
trail will be lost God that double time
your English is very good it came in
handy when I did my postgraduate work up
Brook guy just keeps foot in his mouth
the
wrong those readings were legit
Washington would have sent half the eggh
heads at Los Alamos to check it out Los
Alamos Oppenheimer you want me to lie
and pretend that's not the way things
are m- you're telling me you didn't take
one look at me make a snap judgment
about who I am the second we met white
people white guys are oppressed too it's
not the same they then love I draw the
third suppose it's not you got a lot
more privilege people do make
assumptions but also you get to just
kind of do what you want yeah better
assumptions yeah yeah that's pretty much
it the background's now blurred do you
hear that it's just some
it's John Goodman he made it off the
island yeah he ran all the way across
the
ocean oh the Philippines footage this
son of a [__] ruined everything
liutenant who are you I'm American Navy
vet oh I'm sh well I got the gun swab so
who are you and what are you doing here
my name's William Randa oh can this just
keeps dealing with like lineage and
Legacy it's so fascinating subject to
incorporate here yeah family secrets
he's the son of Randa or is he Randa
himself isn't John Goodman's name Daniel
Randa Danny Randa am I wrong about that
I'm blanking his first name now like
does he become Goodman in 20 years I'm
on a Hunting Expedition I'm a
cryptozoologist studies animals that
don't exist seems like maybe we're out
here hunting for the same thing oh and
John Goodman was trying to send footage
to his son at the very beginning the
footage never got to his son and now
we're watching the
grandchildren cover it okay yes Katie
Where Have You Been I'm sorry I I've
been calling and calling Mom I'm fine
I'm coming home the mom is always only
over the phone we never cut to her yeah
that's got to be intentional somehow
last time you guys like I like at the
mom's like where Where Have You Been
even though she hung up on her last time
right right I I overheard your
accent sometimes this place can make you
feel like you're stranded on another
planet [__] man I don't trust you
one bit where are you headed look I
don't mean to be rude but I've made all
the new friends I can handle from in da
young woman abroad runs into a strange
man at the train station next thing you
know you're buried alive in a coffin
somewhere that sounds like a vaguely
imagine that that helps SK threat
yeah my name's Tim they they don't come
much more harmless than Timber right
have a nice night
Tim I need to talk to you about the
files oh what files I work for
Monarch what's your last name Tim you're
not in trouble not yet those files and
they are more important than you could
possibly imagine oh boy I need to make a
call let's make a
call oh he's doing the arm grab not
looking so harmless right now Tim timoth
Tim what's your last name Tim everyone's
last name seems super important in this
show speaker
please Kate
hello damn right in the nose why didn't
you just do the whole he's trying to
assault me
thingy I said you weren't in trouble yet
you said get how'd he catch up so
fast look I swear we're not going to
hurt
you love how everything he says
contradicts his
actions
n
c
yeah man the PTSD of this Godzilla
event oh Jesus oh
no oh they really Crush that [__] damn
yeah
[Applause]
nice wow these guys are
unscathed yeah ning just shine when's
the last time I answered one of your
text messages
you thought that because of your crazy
family drama that what happened between
us is ancient history it's my right as a
man where you know if you see me I do
audio not home movies I told you I was
sorry apology accepted I'm sorry too
What's your deal I want those old
computer files we found because they're
mine I'm
busy come back tomorrow is she
uncovering what's really busy like
decrypting all that [__]
yeah
jeez what's her last
[Laughter]
name she's related to Brian Tyre Henry
they're both into audio they're both
obsessed with this stuff it's all
connected there's one variable you're
not mentioning that it's very obvious
John oh sure they're both
[Music]
black
she left it in the
bag if you check the security cameras of
the traffic lights you'll see that there
was a gnarly car
accident
[Music]
youing that she's intox inebriated
yeah you could just breath Alize
her
she call the
police cuz we ain't doing [__] to help
you it's a citizenship thing huh you
might be Japanese but you're American at
the end of the day lady you go to the
American Embassy they'll help you out
for sure yeah we get [__] done around
here I like that exchange the paranoia
Monarch's listening Monarch PD
[Music]
I mean it's
complex now that I have acknowledged
your
[Music]
feelings
ouch
she's so great I know she's the best
grieving mother she's got the most heart
out of any
character oh all she cares about is
protecting her son I really think the
mom's going to die she's got the biggest
secret of all she can talk to Godzilla
yeah she was the one who sent Godzilla
to San Francisco to kill their
philandering father
husband so so you guys are following the
radiation aren't you I know you're not
going to find what's out there following
the Geer counter the people of these
mountains they have an oral tradition
about a dragon that carves a path of
fire across the
sky a path of ionizing radiation oh no
that's that's what I was going to say my
orders your orders are to provide me
with whatever my orders are to provide
you with operational security and I
cannot do that with our new friend Billy
the jungle hermit hanging
around Billy the Legacy character just
go then I didn't ask for you and I don't
want you so he looks hurt I'll send
someone back with the
Jeep she's your commanding officer man
so he's Tom Heston yes our guy's John
Goodman the girls Bri
Larson we call them MOS for massive
unidentified terrestrial organisms I
came up with that terrestrial he came up
with that did you hear that yeah
invented it lights in the sky whatever's
making them has been tracing the same
path over and over and over again going
back centuries like comets no more like
migrating birds they're animals these
are the tracks hug the radiation
readings from our surveillance
aircraft
[Music]
wowe
nice it's always satisfying when two
maps click
together like how the hell did they
shoot this I know just I me this is a
great travel log and I do love that even
with the for boing there's a little bit
of Wonder a little bit of the natural
beauty what is
it
Brachiosaurus oh damn whoa what is
that the L this isn't where I parked my
car it's not that [__] from Skull Island
is it no that's in the future skull
Island's in the 70s we're in the 50s yes
God damn it right I have no
idea oh he's John Goodman is what you're
were saying Anders Holm is John Goodman
will will Randa Bill Randa oh so this
guy is John Goodman that we're watching
in the flashback with with in50s
yeah damn it no I got confused too so
confusing I was like is he his son back
home because in in like 15 to 20 years
he's going to be Sean Goodman is a bit
different than the one to one you'll get
with Wyatt and Kurt Russell so yeah I
was like wait a
minute did you
[Music]
Kang out before you even know it well
you have a lovely home
Domo I want Bill randa's files you need
to hand over those files is you your
friends and your mother are going to be
in a lot of
trouble oh boy oh my God you're a
menacing
one just avoid the
[Music]
trouble yeah you know more than you're
letting on ah go find that man amazing
thank
you T you
like n she knows how to distract
yeah oh [__]
[Music]
[__] yeah
buddy this guy is
good that could be a countless
restaurant
yeah went down 200 Mi west of pearl in
1943 Pearl Harbor that's f 5,000 mi from
here oh Hollow Earth spit it back out
you said you study myths stories I'm
interested in why people tell stories
they tell and finding Bigfoot I wonder
how he becomes a crazy cranky old man Mr
R his
hat it's an Easter egg from episode one
you are on this ship yeah wow is this
what you were looking for did you know
it was here did I know maybe let's say
hoped ooh no we hit something in the
water that night we figured it was a
Japanese sub whole ship went down in
less than 3 minutes who else survived
only me damn
damn I'm sorry I've been chasing
Cryptids ever since he really does have
a How I Met Your Mother situation going
on
huh
yeah does that mean that why Russell is
Ted and honor home is
Marshall we need our Bary he turns into
John sure sure sure sure sure I that one
guy turned into Bob zag you know what I
mean yeah Josh rner oh wow oh now you
going to believe somebody's after those
files why don't we just give them what
they want maybe then they'll leave all
of us alone I can get us fake passports
I want a fake passport I want my real
passport I know where to go I know a
white man who can help us trust
me come on a we're going to see caros at
the very end forcing us to wait a
weak
marketing what is that I don't
know oh cool looks organic it's so scary
when they cut to this POV of the camera
I think someone's going to pop right
into
[Music]
frame oh oh creepy aliens and the thing
combined oh
god oh that's so cool there are so many
I want the haunted maze of this when did
you say this chip zck 9 years ago I
think I've seen everything I need to in
here you want some samples of this
translucent pearlescent residue they're
going to wide up somewhere else aren't
they oh I bet yeah like there's like a
rift in time here yeah once they step
out there's like a cool Clover fieldes
quality that they've woven into here
yeah that I think works Cloverfield
Paradox speciic the best Clover
Field but I mean it had a lot going for
it until it
didn't this I say for the rest of the
episode we just review Cloverfield
Paradox while it plays it and rewrite
what could have been
better oh
ctie
[Laughter]
hey look alike yeah they do what's your
name kentaro Randa you're her Roshi's
boy and you I'm kateen he's a Randa huh
yeah I didn't know Hoshi even had a
daughter well I didn't know he had a son
turns out he was good at keeping secrets
she's his real daughter
K we want to ask you about why don't we
um yeah come on let's get some a I like
the little glance he gave to the camera
you want to find out what happened to my
father you tell
me right after gday he said he had some
place he needed to go a week later we
were told the plane he was on
disappeared somewhere in Alaska Monarch
people and
disappeared as in nobody no
got
hey what is this place well this place
is what Monarch euphemistically refers
to as secure Asset
Management H so you're imprisoned here
okay well we're leaving you can try but
they're just going to keep following you
until they finally get what they want
God I love kussell I know choke down
that mountain of Monarch [__] about
your father disappearing Without a Trace
or you can come with me or we can get
the hell out of here right now and find
out what really happened with your dad
so in Kurt Russell now you got just
about 60 seconds to make up your
[Music]
minds oh he just needed the right
Catalyst to get the hell out of here he
been waiting to toss that anklet for
months waiting for that
minivan let's keep it moving yeah
they're not going to come out of the
Jungle they're going to wind up in
Alaska or some [__] y yo whoa whoa
whoa strange sound mix there wow oh oh
that's scary Dam that is a
claw whoa oh this mystery is getting
good
yeah there's your crypted right there
boy
hey holy
[Music]
[__] that's pretty freaky I really
claustrophobic is that a Godzilla claw I
mean it certainly looks like it but why
would just be attacking the ship I don't
think it's him I mean I don't think it's
Godzilla but it's definitely reptile
claw
jeez okay so they are ending up back
here oh my God W run run run run run
run
go oh my oh my oh there it is the TR oh
damn oh [__]
Beast it's not Rodan but it looks kind
of Rodan
esque W
sweepers that's just out in the
open comment below what creature this is
guys yeah it's got to be one from the
pantheon it's that shot of the three of
them just like looking over the ridge
yeah and yeah Randa looking all like oh
what Wonder
Beauty yeah you know what I wonder at
when I'm looking up at things where
people can get the freshest drips at
www.re
shop.com yeah sure it's like that shop
Protection
Services lovely Marvel button down yeah
and then also we got a bunch of other
te's as well over their space babies of
the Galaxy who influences the
influencers and a whole bunch more and
is one of the absolute best ways to
support the channel W this really
depends on you knowing John Goodman's
character name yes and and you know Mak
godamn uh he said William Randa and I
was like okay and then you know Bill is
one of those names you could easily lose
so you're like H yeah no I had to yeah
in that moment I was like is it cuz so
lost
for I get confused I got I got really
lost in the timeline there
with like oh wait which I mean you kept
you kept me on track there man no like
it does 50 7 yeah cuz I was cuz even in
the first episode I was going like okay
cu cu you know I like that they give us
the credit of like okay we're going to
name the years up top and then we're
going to let you keep track as we go
there's a fine line between heavy
Exposition and and letting the audience
be
smart line I am too dumb I blame show
when everyone else is probably able to
keep up just fine well I I do think that
like yeah you know if we were sitting in
complete silence alone you know it
probably wouldn't be that hard but but
they are throwing a good amount at you
and they are jumping back and forth and
they are riding waves of tension between
the two timelines so there are times
when you are just like caught up in the
immediacy of the moment and then you're
like oh wait wait wait and and I also
appreciate they're going back and forth
at times between English and Japanese so
you know like there it's I think asking
that process a little more quickly than
like an average show might and I
appreciate that uh but what you think of
the episode I enjoyed this quite a lot I
think this is building nicely on the
first one and I was you know I mean I
think first and foremost like the
previous episode we were mostly wishing
like yeah I want to you know like really
connect to the characters a bit more but
I'm really loving the build of the
mystery in the world and the you know
lore and all that stuff and here like
they didn't do necessarily like crazy
amounts of character building but I
really enjoyed that much more spending
time with the characters and you know
especially in the past you know
exploring the situation like I thought
in this one it got to breathe quite
nicely of them you know meeting uh uh
the scientist and and Wyatt Russell and
then you know kind of introducing their
Vibe and dynamic and then running into
Anders home out in the wilderness and
how that came to be um and then you know
everything in the present well they did
character building in a different way of
uh holding a teles not a telescope Tes
microscope same concept holding a
microscope uh up in in different areas V
during the dialogue like last episode's
a little bit more setup but then you get
these little nuggets here of like
motivations behind Randa or or a little
bit more subtleties or details I would
say in aspects of the Dynamics and the
conversation back and forth like when in
the past in the 50s when the three of
them are meeting each other and you get
okay you get some about uh Shaw when
he's first introduced bit Apocalypse Now
stylis and Then you get um with the I
forget everyone's name the grandma in
the past uh everyone's name I need to
commit her name in particular cuz yeah
they said it a bunch of times important
character by last name thinking it was a
guy and yeah yeah yeah so the doctor the
doctor and then and then of course Randa
and his past with the war and and uh
understanding their motivation and a lot
of times like some of the character
building just comes in getting you a
little bit more invested in the
character build in the motivation itself
H and and then with the immediate moment
of the of the present or at least the
2015 timeline of the
present with the mom seeming to know a
little bit more than she lets on of the
sun yeah Kent I I am very curious about
him especially because the dad I feel
like he is one of their he's like the
kid of one of them who the the dad uh
the Kento like part of me doesn't
believe that the dad who she came to
Japan to find out about is actually his
dad I almost feel like there's some
weird thing of like he's watch like you
know he looked out for the kid after
like Randa disappeared or
something okay maybe I don't know I'm
just I'm just projecting you know it's
it's but they it's just I don't know
there's the implication is that okay so
we're understanding this Gap here
because there's grandparents and
grandchild that's right yes right that's
what we're we're going with and then
there's Randa who's the grandpa Randa
Being John
Goodman okay which is Bill Randa who
we're seeing in the 50s
the the son is the father of the brother
and sister right am I understanding that
am I am I incorrect about that yes that
would make the most because yeah it
would be both they're both Randa right
both both the brother and sister are
Randa right so then their kid would have
Randa is the last name and could and
would ostensibly be the guy we've seen
in all these pictures so the son is like
when
when Randon in episode one and and and
Asian doctor lady said they had a kid
that kid is the father who mysteriously
disappeared in Alaska right okay yes so
so I'm going to amend my theory slightly
because that that all checks out I I
think yeah I think you're right he
turned into a full Japanese
map it's hard to find a half white half
Japanese actor well yeah you've got you
know uh uh Anders home and and and John
Goodman both don't have like especially
dark you know like hair feature like you
know they have like brownish hair but
they're not like really darkhaired I
like Wizard's a Waverly Place and for
some reason David Henry and Selena Gomez
are brother and sister so I'll get on
board with yeah yeah yeah so just this
kid who looks just completely 100%
Japanese uh yeah but but but now I think
you are correct I am going to put my you
know like bets on your that has to be
right they said they're both randz I
don't know that but I'm saying the name
would pass down but I think maybe the
the idea is that it's actually Kurt
Russell's grandson these are like Kurt
Russell I think one of them is Kurt that
was one of the things we were saying in
last episode that that that one of their
kids is Kurt Russell there you go okay
yeah yeah and that's probably why the
mom was being like you go see this guy
like the missing guy might end up being
his actual son yeah I think Japanese mom
yes
Japan family Rand Randa [__] Japan family
Randa yes that's Kurt Russell yes and
then Americans is not Kurt Russell the
one in America because it seems like
Kurt Russell the r the Russells have
been Shaw have just been in um in Japan
have just remained in Japan this whole
time well it would just make it so that
if he is both of their dad then it just
makes it so that actually Russell is
both of their Granda yeah it's a bit of
a stark situ like a Ned
Starks kind of yeah where like
eventually we might find out that not
only are these two kids how do you have
a family like that yeah like these two
kids are going to wind up having to find
out the truth about their father who was
leading this double life only to
probably find that they are also helping
his father find out more about his son
you know yes and so they all find out by
the end that they are a family yeah and
then the question mark becomes who is
the lady in America who's mom in America
this is this is the real mystery this
who give a [__] about what's going on in
mon like what is the family lineage
exactly the monster [__] is like really
fun and intriguing and I love that side
of the of the lore but in a way it is
much more straightforward than like the
actual implications of what this family
is we know where there I I like that's
the one problem with the Monarch story
line is like we we kind of know a lot
already yeah we do and I and I find it
so they have to make the the mystery of
like where' the dad go the most
intriguing [__] because the stuff of
Monarch I'm like well we know most of it
already if you've seen the three movies
they made yeah and I think it's fun and
interesting that they've done this
because I mean and and you know maybe
maybe we're over complicating things or
something but I feel like in in
addressing the fact that yeah we already
know a lot about Monarch at this point
in time especially and also nobody it's
well documented that no one cares about
humans in any Godzilla related property
like I think they've smartly created
this very sort of convoluted set of just
human circumstances to like oddly make
that more engrossing and and like it's
still drama but it's also like
convoluted enough that it kind of feels
less saddled with being heavy you know
yeah but I I think the the thing though
is like I I I find the brother and
sister who this show started off with
out of everyone here they're the least
interested characters yes and I think
they're putting their all into making
the daughter the most they're trying I
think they want that to be the most
interesting character like with having
the Godzilla trauma uh like and it's
just easily triggered by PTSD she's the
one set up for the most character growth
you know yeah and and but but there's so
many more interesting people than think
surrounding them and like the sun is
really not that interesting to me see
the thing is I'm I'm rooting for the
both of them the son the problem for me
is that ostensibly the lead the the the
daughter whose name I also need to
commit to memory she right now is the
least interesting character oh she's the
least interesting to you okay yeah only
because I put the sun above
her h i find her performance perhaps a
bit more interesting but the thing is
the sun I feel like has just had more
direct focus and a more autonomous plot
whereas like the things that are
interesting about um our lead so far
about Kate are mostly like Godzilla of
PTSD that isn't her specifically it's
like a cool device attached to her and I
don't think her performance is bad like
or anything like that it's just like at
least in this episode she felt like kind
of at the bottom of the totem pole of
things being focused on and I felt like
we just spent the least like she has
that exchange with the guy in the
terminal with Tim in the terminal and
she has to evade and there's the whole
thing with the cops and I think they're
doing like a decent job as much as we
joke and as much as people like to roll
their eyes that you know acknowledging
power structures and how you know social
interactions between men and women in
different races have changed I think
they're they're like nicely kind of
commenting on that stuff but even there
I felt more for the moments between
Wyatt Russell and um and Keiko uh the
doctor uh when they're kind of getting
into that versus her going to the police
station which could have been one of
those very relatable situations I
imagine for a lot of people and women
especially where it's like I am trying
to seek help for an immediate threat and
you're not any help you know and uh and
so yeah I just I I didn't think anything
was bad about her character or or
involvement in the episode it just
didn't feel like they spent much on it
you know yeah and I think they're the
show has is kind of in a weird
Corner
because we know what Monarch is all
about already yeah and this whole show
with our main characters is uncovering
who what Monarch is yes I'm like we we
know what Monarch is yeah and like I
think the show probably works best for
if you've only if this had come out
immediately after Godzilla and Kong if
there was no no I don't even the unique
Kong Skull
Island yeah if it came out after the
first two where we're not spending as
much time with Monarch or I don't know
like yeah throughout those movies
they're dealing with stuff and we're at
least getting glimpses into their
operation there's that whole thing with
Vera formiga and she's got the device
and they're involved with that yeah and
uh yeah I mean like oddly enough like in
this recent glut of like we need to take
these popular franchises and build them
out into shows like a lot of them seem
really ill advised and this to me
actually does not it's just that and and
and that actually doesn't really bother
me that much uh of like I think it's
funny that yeah it's like where can we
something like monarch to me seems like
you could endlessly kind of Dole out you
know interesting little Revelations
because we only saw certain things that
they're working on so I think like there
are still ways to make the shadowy
organization interesting I I I still
overall find the show really fun yeah
really enjoying the show don't get me
wrong yeah but it when when when you
step back though you're like what
exactly are we shining a light on here
within Monarch yeah and it feels like if
they had positioned this after Godzilla
and Kong Skull Island then you could
have it be like we're finding out about
Monarch and then you know occasionally
we're going to look way up you know in
scale you know for this movies like you
know Godzilla king of the monsters or
like Godzilla versus Kong and then go
back to the you know more ground level
stuff and they could develop side by
side but being that we don't live in
that reality I think this is you know
doing a decent job in spite of that you
know yeah yeah cuz they're telling a
conspiracy Thriller right now yeah and I
think adding you know conspiracy sci-fi
thriller yeah yeah totally and and
adding this is already sci-fi and I
hadn't really thought about it even
though there's so much Godzilla already
in all of the Cloverfield stuff but
adding a little bit of that timy wiy you
know
peripheral sci-fi of a slightly
different more surrealist sci-fi sure
just just a sprinkling of that on top of
it is a nice portent for this show sure
sure sure yeah yeah yeah cuz I was fully
expecting them to come out like you know
somewhere else when they were in the
ship you know like like you are like
some kind of time Rift or something yes
yeah I mean especially because it's the
hollow Earth teaser yeah totally yeah um
but right now uh I I'm very it seems
like when we talk about it after that
we're not enjoy I guess it just leads me
to the question cuz like I'm enjoying
everything about like oh the way it's
shot is great the immediacy is very
enjoyable and then I will get pulled
into the immediate moment um and maybe
my mind has just been a little
conditioned when you're doing your show
called Monarch and you're building on a
monster universe for me to think about
what its contribution is to the bigger
part of the universe of like what new
part of the universe but in the
immediacy of the moment I will get
pulled into like the threat and the
perspective when canaro is in the
apartment and Monarch is coming across
like the worst villains of the worst
villains when we really know they're not
actually the worst of the worst and and
and and and you got like a posing you
know tough lady person got Maria
Hill and then the mom has to stall and
that actually happened because I was
like is he gon to go in there and he's
going to like mock something up or or
get some like gummy paper like when he
snuck out I was like oh this is one of
the rare occasions where like that
actually kind of worked on me yeah yeah
it's like the movies always make it seem
like monarch no we need Monarch actually
like that's what they always they're
necessary evil they're yeah like they're
not even that evil they're just doing
some secret government [__] but they
they're always yeah caught up in in the
Pursuits of the people kind of governing
them at the time yeah yeah it's like
sure they they Harbor secrets about the
bigger things of these Titans but
they're not really evil you know they're
not yeah like at least the movies don't
make evil yeah no they they are like a
shadowy faceless organization in ways
that yeah like yeah I think you're right
they're not evil they they're like
chaotic neutral I guess yeah yeah
definitely um and so I will get pulled
into like the the immediacy of what the
characters are feeling a lot of the time
with um you know fearing for their lives
and whatnot and then am I interested in
finding out what happened to the dad
absolutely uh but I am more intrigued by
like oh yeah what did what happened with
Kurt Russ see that's that's the part of
it that I'm really enjoying um is when
I'm hearing like okay what happened with
Shaws like how did he go from that to
where he's being held captive yeah you
know like it's like Resort prison yeah
yeah yeah what happened with um because
we saw JN Goodman die in Kong Skull
Island so what happened with this family
now and how do we get so there's like a
lot of those intrigues I'm very I'm very
much invested in and I want to uncover
that I guess it's when looking at the
the bigger picture of how it factors
into the legacy of monsters it doesn't
really do anything for me there but I
like when the monsters show up I'm just
not because it's like we know what's
going on already there obviously right
like we don't we don't we know what's
going on well that and also we don't
have Kurt Russell in the previous movies
yeah yeah so it's like you know it's a
completely new thing that they're going
to have to you know like just just
conscientiously it's still early though
yeah I'm not doubting it but I'm saying
like the the job they have to do is to
go oh this guy was always involved and
here's why and and maybe why you haven't
heard about or seen him yet up until now
yeah you know I guess to summize it into
the simplistic form what are they going
to discover sure that can lead into like
a oh [__] we have unpacked something
here to the
lore that we could that that has not
been acknowledged yet at all in the
films how are we going to do something
as crazy as like finding Hollow Earth
yeah yeah or cuz we already know what's
happening yeah cuz we'll be excited
about creatures and there is a whole
coder a whole gallery of creatures you
could go for but at the same time that's
I don't think enough to you know really
Propel this for a long time is just
being like Oh which creatur is going to
be next
you make we don't know what creature
that is I'm sure that's some creature
you all [__] know I have no idea who
that is yeah I couldn't identify and now
I'm sitting here half the time going
like okay are they going to make up half
new sort of generic creatures for the
show and then occasionally do like a
famous one are they all going to be
referential yeah but that's fun and
that's the chance to you know there's so
many of these movies and so many
creatures that's a fun opportunity to
you know jump into the expanded cuz you
know not everybody has seen all of the
God's Zilla no but as far as a
conspiracy Thriller goes as far as uh
political Intrigue H I love the music I
love the
direction uh I I I think there's a lot
here that is really really working for
me in the immediate moment I'm having a
really fun time watching it yeah no I'm
really enjoying this and I like
unpacking uh the mystery for the
characters and maybe perhaps I'm getting
too caught up in the bigger picture but
I also blame the show because it's it's
called Monarch Legacy of monsters or
whatever the hell the subtitle
called yeah yeah I think you've you've
trained my I think that sets your mind
up to go to think about those things
yeah no it it totally does yeah and and
then you know it needs it needs instead
of me just going oh we're going to the
thing we know yeah yeah I mean for
people to love it it just needs to make
some sort of impact that feels pertinent
or or you know immediate or vital or
fresh or something and yeah like because
it's it seems focused on the Family's
secret yeah not really Monarch secret
which is probably what the which is what
the show needs sure yeah and I mean you
know there are monarch Secrets within
that but they're not I think yeah it's
kind of smart not to make it like only
about what are the Monarch Secrets
because we do know a fair amount of them
you R into an MCU problem where people
feel like oh I missed something when I
was watching the fall up to Godzilla
versus Kong because I didn't watch their
Apple TV show yeah and maybe and maybe
in a way that is a good inroad if
somebody happens to catch this and they
haven't seen all the monster verse stuff
then they're like oh there's a couple
movies movies beforehand and there's a
couple movies after you know maybe and I
was very disappointed because this show
is so much different than the movies
sure yeah movies are so goodies are so
big do we know how many episodes this
going to be in total this season no idea
six eight okay cuz yeah I mean like I'll
be really Cur like I would be excited if
this is something that can stick the
landing and keep moving because I think
of all again things to spin off into a
series this actually kind of could make
sense whereas a lot of them like you
know what are you
doing um but yeah yeah I don't know I
don't know exactly what it needs to live
up to and I'm not necessarily sitting
here with a specific set of expectations
I think mostly if they can just keep
that air of uh you know just for boing
mystery and that sort of peripheral
sci-fi
eeriness I think that'll go a long way
yeah man I think there's some exciting
things to come and I feel like the dad's
definitely alive yeah he's got to be out
there somewhere I think he's definitely
alive in Alaska he's in Alaska he's just
sitting on an oil tanker th% but yeah
overall still really enjoying the show
and uh I'm excited to see how it
ultimately unfolds and you know we'll
definitely get some more actual Godzilla
soon but what did you guys think leave
your thoughts down below be sure to uh
subscribe leave a like and hey send this
with a patron of the day shout
out all right guys since we only have um
a few day uh only so many days in the
month um we got a shout out two patrons
um but they're going to be that of
sincerity yes heartfelt andness and Love
Stuff love I want to shout out Chris
whof and uh anise Oliva and the same one
so very recent did a live stream and
Chris Wham off who I've thanked many
times for just being the kind of human
being that he is uh who just is a um
real [__] a man for the people tells
like it is tells it like it is man
sometimes you need that t love good from
Chris good moral compass chis did a live
stream and he contributed a
$500 contribution to the stream which is
easily the most anyone has ever
contributed and here's the thing about
Chris is that
um like that was more than generous
needless to say but I know that he's
also giving to other like people who are
also very much more in need than us yeah
and and anyone here and I know he's
actively involved with charitable
contributions in ways that are very
Hands-On and uh I'm grateful that you
would still take the time out and the
money too to help throw her away H and
and a very unexpected manner you could
give more if you weren't contributing to
other things that really I don't see the
significance of it but you know you know
that's your choice could could have been
a thousand is what I'm saying instead of
500 but sure fine 500 I I'll accept that
why not yeah that goes to help pay some
of these people who come here I guess
and Ana
Oliva
and last the time we met up with you in
Santa
Monica and just getting to hang out with
you and treat you to some games and
stuff Pizza just reminded me that you
used to contribute a lot to our live
streams what happened I thought I
reignited that Chris is holding it down
single-handedly Chris is literally doing
so you you should you should be giving
every I thought I invested money into
the time you're were out here in Santa
Monica and it would come back via
massive live stream
yeah and right now I'm just at a
financial negative now yeah because
write that off yeah this is actually I
can yeah I guess thetically but that's
not the same as you contributing more
you know so um what gives yeah Ana uh
but Chris how much is there to do in
thank you for being you but Ana come on
lady what are you you are not Chris
there cannot be that much in Texas that
requires is your time and hard-earned
dollarin I don't get what working at
hospitals what toll does that really do
yeah sometimes we have to wake up early
rarely wake up early to do a trailer
it's tough I'm telling you man I need my
sleep yeah I need my I need my 12 hours
definitely I need my 16 hours so you're
not
helping and that's all we have to say
about that all we got for you
yeah
no no I want to thank you Ana because I
know that we are just Justin here and
that I love
how love how comfortable I am with you
and I'm really grateful for that that I
really do feel like I can be my full
real self around you make jokes like
that or um it wasn't a joke it was Ser
no make make jokes like that and um and
then have like a real conversation as
well and
I it's it's actually a little bit harder
for me to find that more and more these
days and and I and and your spirit just
sort of allows for that and I I'm really
grateful for that so thank you for thank
you for being you and you have in all
fairness which she guys the joke is
rooted in the fact that she has
contributed massive
amount in so many ways over so much time
why people would pressure her and just
giving it such a ridiculous joke so yeah
you're covered for a few years there yes
but I mean for sheer force of love and
enthusiasm and just being there for for
so many things I'm Hing this leads to
more money oh sure that's that's what
you want to convert it all into over
time you know if you got
some in a strong way they're like
longevity they're always here thank you
there's always a stream to the
re we love you
unconditionally and we will talk to you
soon and hopefully hang out again
sometime soon and Chris can come along
we can all get together that would be
fun be the would be fun cuz you know
that Chris would pay for us whereas
would make us pay for her that's true
and by proxy Chris would pay for Ana
this is just not fair me yeah you can't
take advantage of Chris's kindness after
after we do we do it's not fair not fair
to do
[Music]
d